- [Instructor] Alejandro
was curious if sample median
was an unbiased estimator
of population median.
He placed ping pong balls
numbered from zero to 32
in a drum and mixed them well.
Note that the median of
the population is 16.
He then took a random
sample of five balls,
and calculated the median of the sample.
He replaced the balls,
and repeated this process
for a total of 50 trials.
His results are summarized
in the dotplot below
where each dot represents
the sample median
from a sample of five balls.
So this right over here
is a sampling distribution
of the sample median.
You have a population of balls.
We know a parameter.
We know that the median
of the population is 16.
This right over here is the population.
And then he keeps taking
samples of five balls,
so that is five-ball
sample right over there.
And then he calculates the statistic,
the median of the sample,
so he calculates the median
there, and he does it again.
He calculates the median,
and he does it again.
He calculates the median.
And then he does this 50 times.
He does this 50 times.
And so, what you see plotted
over here, do you see 50 dots?
Every time he took a sample of five balls,
and calculated the median,
we see that as one of the dots here.
So for example, four times,
he calculated a median of 20.
Two times, he calculated a median of 19.
One time, he calculated a median of four.
Now they ask us, based on these results,
does the sample median
appear to be a biased
or unbiased estimator of
the population median?
So pause this video, and
see if you can come up
with an answer to that.
In order to be an unbiased estimator,
and that is what you want
your estimator to be,
you want it to be unbiased,
the sampling distribution
for that statistic
has to be evenly distributed
about the true parameter
for the population.
So for example, in this situation,
the true parameter for the population
is a note that the median
of the population is 16,
so that's the thing that
you're trying to estimate.
So this is where the median
of the population is.
And so, if we look at the
sampling distribution,
we see that it is roughly balanced
to the left and to the right
of that true parameter.
So I would say that this
is looking pretty unbiased
because the sampling distribution
is evenly balanced to
the left and the right
of the true median of the
population, that true parameter.
If, for some reason,
the distribution looked
something like this,
then it would not be unbiased.
Or if the distribution
looked something like this,
if the distribution looked like this,
if our sampling
distribution was like this,
this would mean that we're
consistently underestimating
the true parameter.
And if our distribution looked like this,
this means that our
statistic is overestimating
the true parameter.
Let's do another example.
The dotplots below show an approximation
to the sampling distribution
for three different estimators
of the same population parameter.
If the actual value of the
population parameter is five,
which dotplot displays the
estimator with both low bias
and low variability?
Pause this video,
and see if you can come
up with the answer.
So the population parameter
that we're trying to estimate is five.
So let's show that on each
of these distributions,
these approximations of
the sampling distributions.
Over here, we have our scale.
This should be one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
and one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
And so, our population parameter is five,
so that is right over there,
that is right over there,
and that this is right over here.
Which of these statistics
seem to be biased?
Let's just start there.
Pause this video.
Which of these look biased to you?
The one that looks clearly
biased is statistic C.
When you look at its
sampling distribution,
it is consistently to the
left of our true parameter,
so it's consistently
underestimating our parameter,
so this one right over here is biased.
Now statistic A and statistic B
both look reasonably unbiased.
Remember, these are approximations
of the sampling distribution.
If you want to get closer and closer
to the sampling distribution,
the true sampling distribution,
you would keep taking samples,
and keep calculating the statistic,
and keep plotting them on this
distribution right over here.
But for statistic A, it
looks reasonably balanced
to the left and the right.
It's not perfectly balanced
but it's reasonable.
Remember, these are approximations.
And statistic B is also
reasonably balanced
to the left and the right.
Now they don't just say
which one has a low bias
but they also say low variability.
I would say both statistic
A and statistic B
have relatively low bias
but if we talk about low variability,
that's how much spread do they have,
especially around the true parameter.
And it looks like statistic
A has much lower spread
than statistic B right over here.
In statistic B, you've
calculated statistics
that are too way from the true parameter
while in statistic A, you've
calculated a statistic
of certain samples that
are roughly half away
from the true parameter.
So the statistic that has both
low bias and low variability,
that would be statistic A.